حققت أكبر عملة مشفرة في العالم ، عملة
البيتكوين ، علامة فارقة أخرى عندما
قفزت إلى مستوى قياسي بلغ 60
ألفًا ، في إشارة إلى أن العملات الرقمية
أصبحت قوة متنامية في
الأسواق المالية ، مما أدى
إلى توتر البنوك الكبرى
والحكومات
مع تأمل دبي في أن تقود الطريق التي كانت دبي
بها.  دائمًا ما تكون في طليعة
تبني التقنيات الرقمية بشكل صحيح ،
هناك اتجاه قوي
لجلب هذه التقنيات الجديدة
والعملات المشفرة وتقنيات blockchain التي
تريد الإمارة أن تصبح
مركزًا عالميًا لاستثمارات التشفير التي تقوم
برقمنة معظم
معاملات الشركات الحكومية والخاصة خلال السنوات القليلة المقبلة
والقلب النابض  تتم هذه الاستراتيجية
هنا
في مركز دبي للسلع المتعددة أو
DMCC ، والفكرة هي حقًا إنشاء
وادي سطح السفينة في دبي ، وسيكون الكثير منه
رقميًا ولكن سيكون هناك أيضًا
هدف
dmcc المادي لتوفير منصة مركزية ومنظمة
سيدير جميع الأنشطة المتعلقة بالعملات المشفرة في
عداد ال
دينة  ng للشراء في عصر التشفير
، سيحدث ذلك ، من الأفضل أن نمتلك
المعرفة على الأقل ،
وبعد ذلك عندما يحين الوقت لاستخدامها
، يكون لديك الأدوات
التي تشبه معظم المنتجات المالية الجديدة.
كل شيء
بحاجة إلى التسوية مع تطوير التكنولوجيا ،
وهناك الكثير من علامات الاستفهام حوله ،
على سبيل المثال ، ما هو تأثير
العملات المشفرة التي تظهر على الشاشة في
النظام المصرفي ،
ومن غير الواضح تمامًا بالنسبة لشركة dmcc التي
تخلق بيئة آمنة لشركات التشفير
هي خطوة حاسمة  لجذب
ثقة وأمن الاستثمارات ، لن يتم
إطلاق هذا دون
تغطية جميع القواعد ، فمن خلال هذه
المبادرات ، تريد دبي
تسريع الانتقال إلى العملات المشفرة على
أمل أن تكون في وضع جيد بحلول الوقت الذي
يصبح فيه المال الرقمي حضورًا رئيسيًا في
الاقتصاد العالمي.
سي ان ان دبي
لك